>>The whole point of the fact that
it's not permanent or easy to edit is
that you're supposed to
experiment with ideas.
You're supposed to--
>>Narrator: Exceptional teachers
who are continuously
learning are critical
to the success of High Tech High.
>>Randell: You're supposed
to be stretching out.
I would I love it if you're on
the edge of what you understand.
>>Larry: What I like to see
in a teacher is somebody
who has deep content knowledge
of their subject matter.
>>Teacher: 'Cause even if nobody
reads your words, they say, "Gee,
what a nice balanced
document that looks like."
>>Student: Right.
>>Larry: Somebody who is passionate
about their subject matter.
>>Teacher: No, no no, I like
how it bounces back and forth.
>>Larry: And people who are
very dynamic in their ability
to infect kids' curiosity.
>>Jay: And you wanna check it
out, write down some observations,
what it smells like,
what it looks like.
>>Narrator: Teachers like
these are hard to find,
so High Tech created an onsite
credentialing program, and later,
a graduate school of education to
train its own teachers and leaders.
>>Stacey: Finish
up in a couple minutes
and switch to the other person.
>>We started about four years ago,
credentialing our own teachers,
and offering an intern program
so that we could hire teachers
who we wanted and then they could
pursue their credential through us,
rather than going to a local
university and kind of having things
that weren't quite as
relevant to what we do here.
>>Rob: This is a silent
exercise and when it is over,
we'll look at what we've got
and make some comments about it.
What I'm looking for, and I
think what we're all looking
for is an adult who's interested
in what and how kids think.
>>Randell: What else did you
notice about Anna's writing?
Mariah, take it away.
>>Student: Each topic she has is, if
you like look at it all, it's a lot,
but because she spaces
it out, it doesn't seem
as much when you're reading it.
>>Rob: So when we see teachers
doing a demonstration lesson here,
and they're engaging kids in
dialog in some way or another,
and they're asking kids the questions
and probing and trying to get
at what they're thinking,
I at least think, "Wow,
this is someone who
we can work with."
>>Randell: Was there anything
good out there in those blogs?
Little bit?
>>All right, a lot.
Okay, Isaac, get us
started, what you see, man?
>>Narrator: Eleventh grade teacher
Randy Scherer is earning his master's
degree at High Tech's
graduate school?
>>Randell: A traditional approach
might be to spend eighty percent
of your time researching theory,
and then only at the end, "Oh,
now take this to the world."
>>The grad school has been really
an interesting place to be,
because we start in the world,
and then we go find out, "Well,
what are the theories
that really support this?"
>>Anthony: How do we
visualize debt, Samantha?
>>With money.
>>Anthony: With money.
So like, debt is like money you owe.
So when you're in debt, is that
a good thing or a bad thing?
>>Everybody: Bad thing.
>>That's a bad thing.
>>Narrator: Anthony
Conwright has spent a third
of his life at High Tech.
>>Anthony: It started
when I was fourteen.
I went to a really bad
school, and my mom heard
of this crazy school
called High Tech High.
>>So you got it?
>>Narrator: He was among the
school's first two hundred students,
and graduated in 2003.
>>Anthony: And right after
high school, I started working
at High Tech Middle, 'cause
it had just opened up,
and I've been here ever since.
>>Anthony: -- four plus five.
>>Narrator: Now twenty two, Conwright
is pursuing a teaching credential.
>>Anthony: We'll work our
way to find four plus five.
>>Narrator: Video recordings are
made of his work in the classroom
and are used in evaluation
meetings for feedback
from his peers and from students.
>>Does anybody have
clarifying questions?
>>Student: Do you have a separate
lesson for subtracting integers?
>>I have them do each-- this
page in their table groups,
and I went around to each table
group and just checked in--
>>As a teacher, I don't feel like
any of what's going on is about me.
It's completely about the students,
and that's what I love here, is like,
everything is about the students,
the students first, their needs.
How can we make learning
more efficient?
How can we make it fun?
>>Student: So there's seven money
slips, with the negative sign,
so it's like to negative seven.
>>Narrator: The graduate school
of education is fully integrated
with the life and work of High Tech
High's K through Twelve schools.
>>Student: Point one,
which is that line--
>>Narrator: Helping to make this
an environment where everyone,
no matter their age, is a learner.
>>Student: And you go
seven feet up from the top.
>>Anthony: Yeah, see that, nice.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org